[Music]
welcome
welcome welcome we're going to play
phasmophobia
live it's a horror game i'm going to
play with ken
evelyn and jack i don't know anything
about it but they played it before
say hi hey hey
that's so weird to hear your
directionality
how you doing over there pretty good
i fired it so i don't want you guys to
smell it that's fair
thank you
[Music]
i got some real injector going on how's
the basketball
whoa hell yeah she scorns
how do you grab it i feel it's ready up
uh e and then three is to throw
g for gamer
yeah good job gamer oh you wanna see me
go you wanna see these moves yeah do it
watch this
yeah real nice oh he whipped it
oh we all suck again again come back
okay catch this catches all right yeah
yeah yeah got it all right catch give me
the rock
all right over here
yeah the layup you got this
oh my god i can see your tongue ken yeah
62 is pretty good okay maybe it's 58
yeah
maybe 50.
maybe we're possessed all right so you
see this bottom part it says that we
have to say the name is charles white
and it responds to everyone being in
groups together the voice recognition
you can't do that jack
top 10 spooky moments jackson number 15.
this one okay so
you have to right click on the radio to
turn it on and then you can ask the
ghost questions
charles white crumoy's
critical
if you say too many times you'll get
angry and attack you it's a television
felix
is here we got a tv ghost guys over
shut up is this the basement oh my god
your shadow in the basement door scared
the [ __ ] out of me
jack stick with me please where are you
charles white are you here
where do you go charles white hello
charles white is a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] no no
no don't say that don't say anything
where are you
kill pewdiepie i'm running out of
flashlight i can't
okay okay i'm doing it okay i think it's
the uh i think it's the bathroom i think
it's down the coast
oh
charlie charlie are you here oh emf of
2.
oh oh charles white this is
charles white you hear a mess all right
you need to
drop something and pick this up it's the
camera you take pictures if you right
click
you gotta take a picture of the ghost
well right click takes the picture and
you only have four pictures left you
gotta uh
oh three pictures left you gotta try and
get a picture of the ghost that's our
last thing we gotta do okay no problem
yeah
but he was in the bathroom last time
charles white
charles white he's a [ __ ]
he's all right hey
oh that's the one i have charles there's
just a green light on it and it doesn't
take pictures
charles white oh yeah so okay felix
yo felix press j yeah press j and then
hit the
two arrows to take you to the end yeah
that'll give you a thing with all your
evidence on it
um scroll through ever evidence one is
emf level five so just scroll to that
yeah evidence two is ghostwriting yeah
keep hearing a door and evidence three
is spirit box
okay so then at the bottom you can flick
through and it tells you what ghost it
is so the three evidence
it's in give you the one option for oni
yeah so you have to hover
you have to leave it on that and then we
leave and we have identified the ghost
properly
ah yeah so we gotta if we keep saying
its name we're going to make it real
angry okay we can try and make it take a
picture let's do a diss
track i don't want to die though
come on guys charles white have fun more
like charles
isn't all right charles white
what was that yeah i heard that too are
you in the bathroom talking too oh you
are okay
there you go good luck buddy
charles white more like [ __ ] i'm a
fight
hey charles white charles white tell us
why we come in peace
let's
anybody got photo cameras they can bring
oh i haven't done this one i have a
camera yeah
spoopy ghost game big big ghost gang all
right let's stick together guys let's
not split up
yeah we should actually split up because
it's so huge oh my god what did i just
say what did i just say
what's the what's the name of the ghost
over i
don't know helen jones why am i
following you
i don't know
i think i heard something upstairs oh we
should go upstairs okay yeah we got to
call the ghost
helen jones we come in peace
we're gonna tap that helen no i don't
you run i don't come in peace where are
you at girl i'm ready to fight oh
you gonna let him speak to you like that
helen jones yeah what kind of loser
haunts a school
yeah kids are weak i mean
i'm weak dunk your head in the toilet
and give you a wedgie what are you it
yeah
i'll i'll just get in your school box
whoa wow yeah aggressive no that's
normal in sweden we should get in each
other's school box
give us a sign helen jones yo there's
there's a poop
there's a poop i get in here there's a
poop bucket in here
i
[Music]
oh god
look at it it's all liquid ew
oh what the hell did he eat bro that's
impressive in the mouth
yeah that's normal you know twice a day
all right ellen jones
what's wrong with you guys shut up huh
what helen jones what's up girl
kind of cute you know i saw a picture of
you show yourself
for real you did helen jones show me
your toes
oh feed pics feed pics come on helen
felix why are you rocking around with a
crucifix out
uh no reason can't detect anything with
a crucifix
should we go all right should we check
downstairs
yeah yeah maybe
again i think we should check downstairs
again
upstairs anymore we should probably just
check downstairs
i can't find anything upstairs i think
maybe
i think there's speed picks down
upstairs it's probably downstairs
uh i checked everywhere upstairs so
there's only one logical
there's nothing in this upstairs room
maybe the downstairs will have more
i've looked around upstairs for a while
i think i just heard a woman i heard
i heard cricket downstairs so i think we
should check downstairs
we think we should go the ghost said i'm
downstairs so i think we should check
downstairs we haven't even
been checking this bridge where's the
downstairs for real where's the
downstairs
i think i heard the ghost laugh did you
guys hear that yeah
kind of insane it sounded like really
bad voice acting
where would you guys go downstairs i
don't know where the stairs are but i
think we should go
down them all right guys we're
downstairs oh yeah we should check the
logs
yeah i think it's upstairs uh yeah we
checked downstairs let's we should
probably check up soon
it's way louder up here uh i i found the
sink earlier
oh who did that whoa
three degrees in here it's this room
nice come on oh my god i got a five i
got a five i got a five
hell yeah what's her name helen small
helen small
is she taking a dump girl you ain't
jones
helen jones all right let's close the
door and everyone turn up the lights
and okay no she's in the boys bathroom
what the [ __ ] helen this is bad for my
sanity
she's gone guys we lost her oh
it's oh god it's back it's me she's
breathing on my neck right now
whoa
closer closer or closer why it says gab
again
oh jesus christ what did you guys hear
that
no no she just said
oh we got them right now she breathed my
neck earlier
lights off okay no freezing temperatures
for uh fingerprints
scare me you scare me
no it wasn't he's lying i didn't i
didn't hear anything
lights are flashing she's about to
attack out
he's going down y'all a bunch of cowards
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm a ghost
oh
hello come on girl what's up jack
can you hear me from this netherrealm
felix's dead body
jack can you hear me
all right he's got a bit of heat left in
him no one likes you
you're stinky pooper
[Music]
we're done here i guess she didn't want
to get feedback yeah that makes sense
you close the front door
i'm back guys welcome back
she lives
oh so we should all spread out then
it's already chilly in there yeah the
people
i'm going upstairs i'm going into the
basement
oh yeah i'm gonna scare them where they
go
i just dropped my glow stick there
hi paul jackson who's your favorite nfl
team
what are you doing
what are they doing i don't know
nice house i don't know where this is
[Music]
get in there
how are you even doing that
[Music]
it's a snoring
no it's a closet downstairs are upstairs
it's edgar
you knew it that's not freezing look
guys it's a gamer sink
starter ghost led yo
gamer toilet what's up wow
tick tock tick tock what's up oh
oh oh it's doing it it's doing it it's
in the garage yeah
we should send in one at a time uh
evelyn you you go first
oh okay i'm gonna die bye four on the
emf
there's no ghost orbs yet nice ankles
girl
and you're right
[Music]
oh
my turn my turn what was his name what
was his name again
jackson paul jackson you [ __ ]
[Music]
nice nice whoever picked up the camera
making me motion
what is happening
everyone's walking through that door
what the [ __ ] it's so scary
what do you why is it scary because you
walked through the door
the door was closed it was closed
oh my god so far all right let me
leave him in the garage i'll be with
paul jackson
paul jackson make two knocks for yes
one knock for no are you subscribed to
pewdiepie
ah
i feel like i would see ghost herbs
though
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i asked if he was subscribed to
pewdiepie and he said no
oh no move the camera somewhere
here might be in another room
for sure
we got fingerprints spirit box and
freezing temperatures so
guys okay everyone turn around and
crouch
no someone in chat says the right thing
and then jack crouch as well
ken you got to look in the camera man i
don't know up up up
up up too much everlasting so much it's
not that that that
that yeah
can you guys hear me yes guys guys i got
the song i got this oh thanks man
all right all right whoa whoa right into
the action eh
what the [ __ ] dude yeah oh no now it's
echoey
it said echo in here echoey
quack says the light
don't judge me all right keep moving
keep keep moving
sometimes you should just not rhyme
words keep moving that sounds similar in
your head
okay keep moving keep going
so i have a sniffle
the ghost is leaking out of my head
ectoplasm
okay i drop here i'm going downstairs
no no ken can't can't we gotta stick
together ken
we can't lose you again what do you mean
again
backing noms this is my diary you want
to read it yeah
dear diary today in school people maybe
i'll mess with my flashlight right now
today people made fun of my green hair
mommy says
it's green goldilocks i hope one day
i will become a rainbow wow
hey they went left let's go this way
right gang okay that just goes at the
end of the hallway left gang
why do we walk so slow i don't i don't
know
we got a phone we got a phone we get a
phone everybody
guys felix is possessed
he's possessed by an even bigger dumbass
i crush my fingers
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
do you want to step in the shower for a
little bit sure
i don't think the ghost is in here just
like i'm getting that vibe
yeah if anything if anything we scare
the ghost away
uh should i place the salt somewhere
i'll place a salt here so we're
protected
it's a mirror i did it i did it i did it
all right
all right we're protected
guys don't don't trip on the salt on the
way out oh emily
guys don't trip on the salt don't trip
at the ghost
he's okay
came out of the room stop the crap out
of me
are you okay feeling
look at that activity damn it was mad at
you big man
what did i do they just put salt dude
back in the room the ghost stores are
back in the room again so this one's
back
oh i should have used the crucible the
salt did nothing
nothing
[Laughter]
i don't think salt works against this on
my little i don't think it works either
there's me like his hand his face this
is a cute one
he's looking up from the corner yeah
that one
it's the best one that was fun i enjoyed
that
is that how you guys saw me when i was
in the club don't tell me that's what i
look like please
yeah no your flashlight was sneaking up
that's what i came up with what are you
doing
make sure you become a member shout out
to all the members
[Music]
rufus
you